[Musique]
alors silence en studio on roule on
tourne c'est l'émission de tam-tam
canada en direct de montréal avec
l'équipe fantastique l'équipe de rêve
ici même en studio
marie claude simard bonjour nous
apprécions tout ça en fait à l'antenne
avant ça nous étions des voix
désincarnée maintenant projeté le boeuf
à l'émission raymond des marteaux
bonjour moyens mois déjà d'une chose je
ne vois pas arrêter une phase parfaite
pour faire de la radio la télévision et
puis web chante elle était avec nous
longeons chantal bonjour stéphane alors
tous ensemble aujourd'hui on va jouer
avec plaisir ce stéphane connu alors
celle humblement way écouter à
l'émission on joue normalement vous le
sel ont joué avec la grosse boule ya
trois jeux vous perdez des points c'est
très drôle mais aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
peut-être qu'on va jouer davantage
encore il ya notamment la régie auquel
on va lancer un défi
quel autre surprise à l'initiative du
tout non pour cela je vous préviens tous
attention surprise le bas-manhattan
vençois présent dit tout ce que je vais
recevoir à noël période je ne dise pas
drôle alors vous connaissez la tradition
on change pas sa c5 image une vidéo la
vidéo numéro un comme on l'appelle
dignement et voici les cinq images ou
des voeux ni le thème de l'émission
aujourd'hui
la santé mentale c'est aux sabots
absence mais encore au cancer du cerveau
non mais ça se passe dans le cerveau le
mental sa volée moquer oui bon mais lily
la fameuse troisième protéines potentiel
dans le cadre de l'alzheimer vous savez
ça a un lien avec leurs âmes heures
également
oui mais la grande image là voici la
5ème nous révèle le fond de la faire je
pense
la masseuse vidéo wall e juste du oui
pour les aînés alors si vous avez parmi
vos prêts personnes et mes préférés des
aînés peut-être que vous allez tirer
aujourd'hui la science de cette émission
le jus un la vie pour offrir un cadeau
peut-être un anniversaire à noël je dis
tout de suite elle me fit non merci
alors aujourd'hui à parler de cette
santé des cerveaux des aînés et grâce
aux jeux vidéo notamment avec une
spécialiste qui s'appelle sylvie
belleville
elle a un grand titre et dans le m 2 je
vous réserve la surprise soit dans
quelques instants mais s'est intéressée
à l'impact qu'ont ces jeux par exemple
super mario 64
vieux jeu mais ça fonctionne encore
aujourd'hui ça procure des résultats dit
elle alors au premier tour de la grosse
boule aujourd'hui bien sûr c'est parti
nos questions aujourd'hui l'émission
c'est toujours le jeu vidéo c'est qu'il
ya deux boutons mais c'est fin c'est sur
les manettes 4 6 boutons lors je me suis
dans premier tour de la grosse boule on
a fait ch à l'antenne la régie encore
une fois écrites ou sans fautes
d'orthographe
ça va apparaître dans le sun la façon un
peu fâché avec moi alors à la régie ça
va mais pas de souci écoutez on y va
voilà alors on dit que l'industrie des
jeux vidéo canadienne bondi à pas de
géant au pays mais par boc de s'est
tenue au québec à cause du fort voici la
question marie-claude le canada est le
lieu de conception de quel pourcentage
de tous les jeux vidéos qui sont mis sur
le marché chaque année dans le monde
alors jean talon avec la réponse et 20 %
20 % c'est mon choix de réponses étaient
10 15 et 20
voilà et aucune de ces réponses aucun de
ceux mais moi je vais dire 10 % 10 %
aucune de ces réponses vraiment vous
avez le compris finalement c'était que
ne seraient comme sa raison d'un petit
astérix qui se trouvaient devant aucune
de ces réponses
[Rires]
j'espère qu'il donnera pas d'autres
comme ça les missions qui vont se passer
vraiment j'ai l'accord sur commande là
il a eu un coup de pouce s'est pas joué
pour lui c'est ok de retard par ses
réponses mais c'est quand même ses gonds
c'est plus haut c'est plus bas alors
pour ça
de tous les jeux vidéo sont conçus par
des canadiens mais il faut dire qu'on
représente 0 5% de la population
mondiale
donc c'est quand même un exploit mais
attention quand on parle des champions
dans le monde de la création des jeux
vidéo il faut parler du québec de
montréal en particulier le mans il ya
des capitales dans le monde via le japon
est à la californie et ya le québec qui
serait un l'accord également beaucoup de
pays se retrouvent à lady di pourcentage
assez important alors c'est une c'est un
commerce qui résonne un boom dans
plusieurs nations où il ya mienne mais
vraiment des grands centres notamment
montréal via paris également watts qu'en
france et puis non comment on va
regarder ça ensemble aujourd'hui pour le
moment on va vers une des spécialistes
n'ont pas des jeux vidéo mais de
l'utilisation des jeux vidéo tel que
promis à la fin thérapeutique
oui à des femmes arrêtées rapporte un
journaliste répond oui c'est ça elle
veut des précise la france et l'uruguay
se sont alors à ce que parce que ça
seulement allaient me l'a pas loin voici
l'acteur sylvie belleville professeur
titulaire au département de psychologie
à merci bonjour professeur est ce que
vous nous entendez bien et bien est-ce
que vous noyer dans 64 couleurs comme
sur le jeu commodore ouais tout va bien
alors on vous a évité parce que c'est
pas la première fois que à radio canada
ont fait référence à votre étude qui
sans faire référence dans le domaine de
l'impact que peuvent avoir les jeux
vidéo la pratique des jeux vidéo prix
personnes aînées
d'abord comment comment s'est déroulée
cette enquête de votre part quelles
étaient vos pistes et puis comment ça se
passait en laboratoire ou à la maison
dans la vie privée des gens mais écoutez
ça fait longtemps qu'on s'intéresse dans
le
dans le milieu aux effets d entretenir
la stimulation cognitive chez les aînés
donc la stimulation cognitive ça peut
être un professeur de bien des façons de
faire ça n'importe quelle activité
ludique comme par exemple par une
seconde langue nous apprendre la musique
ou jouer d'un instrument mythique
donc il ya beaucoup d'intérêt pour ça et
où enfin cette petite particulièrement
s'intéresser le jeu vidéo qui on a
comparé les trois types d'interventions
l'intervention avec un jeu vidéo c'était
mario 60 x 60 kg super mario 64 et puis
aussi un entraînement était par
ordinateur même des gens prenaient de la
musique vont vous apprenez à faire du
piano finalement et on veut contrôler
ont examiné les gens qu'ils fassent
cette activité particulière et après
l'activité pour voir les changements au
niveau de la commission qui au niveau du
cerveau et ça c'est une étude pour
marcher en troc avec icaunais de
l'université montréalaise engler donc
des collègues qui s'intéressait
particulièrement celles qui sont très
rapides
bon bon bon ça va quand on parle
d'années dans le cadre de cette étude là
on parle de quel âge environ
parce que c'est un peu vague est né pour
moi ce que je vais faire de jaman entre
55 76 ans avec une moyenne d'à peu près
60 entre 55 et 70 engins volants de la
moyenne donc quatre ans est né à ces
mecs dans le vieillissement c'est à 6
c'est en continuant le vieillissement
tendance à venir
quand on est dans la question je vais
mettre face à face les aînés bien sûr
les jeunes on sait qu'il ya une rue une
étude récente de l'organisation mondiale
de la santé qui met en garde contre la
surexposition des jeunes aux jeux vidéo
parce que ces jeux là auraient
deux impacts plutôt négatif sur leur
santé à quel rythme
l'exposition des aînés à ces jeux là
devrait être plutôt bénéfique pour eux
écouter observer moi je suis dit mais là
à parler de bénéfique et pas bénéfique
parce que pour moi en jeu vidéo comme
n'importe quelle activité
elles ont un effet sur le cerveau après
il faut comprendre la nature des effets
je vous donne l'exemple de ce jeu alors
c'est un jeu on leur demandait de le
faire plusieurs fois par semaine
évidemment je vous dis tout de suite il
n'aimait pas ça véhicule d abandonner et
il le faisait parlement est ce que les
uns ni même fait beaucoup jouer avec des
jeux vidéo mais ce qu'on a observé c'est
qu'il y avait des changements ou de
certaines images en 3d notamment la
région pour la paix lui portant qui est
une structure du cerveau qui sait à la
mémoire d'une structure quand même très
important qu'elle vaut mémoriser des
conversations sonores début on retire
donc je vais regarder la paille de vie
portant et augmenter la mémoire et on ne
vous souhaite pas d'une région et d'un
dissident l'attention visuelle donc
alors que la musique elle augmentait
aussi certaines régions mais d'autres
régions plus imputer justement dans le
traitement de ces tendances ce que ça
nous inquiète c'est un tracé que dépend
d'un jeu et de jeu contient on va avoir
des effets différents sur le service ici
c'est un jeu où il ya beaucoup
d'exploration et c'est pour ça que l'ivg
en était dense et de la cgil car vous et
je vous interrompre une seconde
ce compteur d'un vieux jeu dont
plusieurs personnes n'ont pas idée qu'il
a déjà estime vraiment les sondés maddin
on passe d'un jeu à l'autre
est ce que vous auriez pu pourquoi je
vais arrêter sur le choix par exemple de
mario est ce que vous auriez pu utiliser
un autre jeu faisant appel à
l'orientation visuel il ya des jeux de
simulation plus récents pourquoi seul
utilisent celui là prêt parce que
c'était plus facile
au niveau des planètes et avait quatre
boutons seulement aux jeunes se trouvent
entre autres pour cela et on sait aussi
que les aînés ils sont très réfractaires
à utiliser par exemple des jeux de deux
tirs
donc on voulait quelque chose qui
intéresse un minimum les aînés mais qui
nécessitait cette exploration dans
l'espace qui qui ont une étude aussi qui
date quand même de parce que vous savez
quand on publie une étude c'est une
étude qu'on a passé plusieurs années à
20 de l'homme cela fonctionne la
recherche
mais c'est sûr qu'actuellement il faut
s'intéresser aux jeux qui sont
présentement disponibles sur le plan
commercial et essayer de voir les effets
sur le cerveau parce que les jeux
actuels une caractéristique c'est qu'ils
ont des gps évier et donkey kiwi et ça
on s'inquiète parce que ça veut dire
l'avantagé ce joueur ce qui faut il
fallait se faire une représentation
spatiale dans l'espace de
l'environnement donc on explorait en
trois dimensions vous voyez un peu dans
une valise enfin on est leurs différents
environnements en trois dimensions ce
que la gauche à droite donc on se fait
ni représentation spéciale de
l'environnement et ça on sait que certes
emule l'ipo quand j'entends au delà de
la stimulation cognitive comme vous l'aï
dit tantôt
quels sont les autres effets que vous
avez observé durant cette étude est ce
qu'on peut considérer le jeu vidéo comme
un outil de socialisation pour les aînés
ah c'est pas une petite socialisation
ici vraiment on a quelqu'un qui est
devant son ordinateur et qui fait qu'ils
jouent un jeu vidéo se met par contre
une petite parenthèse et que plus on
utilise d'autres technologies par
exemple réalité virtuelle avec les ailes
juteux jean macé à trié par le fait que
les aînés qu'ils arrivent sont très
excités de rentrer dans la technologie
et ils vont nous faire est comme un père
comme j'ai hâte de raconter ça mon petit
fils je vais pouvoir
agir avec lui dès qu'est ce que j'ai
fait en tant qu il ya une certaine forme
pour les uns et d'excitation guillou
fait qu'on l'aimé ou qu'on sait qu'il ya
beaucoup de tours stigmatisation chez
les aînés par rapport donc le fait de
les mettre en contact avec ça que ceux
qui font mumuse avec mais ceci dit nous
élirons voir spontanément passer des
heures devant un jeu vidéo ce que les
jeunes vont faire donc l'alpha chez les
aînés actuel est probablement très
différents par contre les élites de
demain
c'est une chose tout à fait je voudrais
que les gens de 35 ans par exemple
d'écrans d'utilisateurs de jeux vidéo
je servais très important d'examiner
l'impact d'acteurs belleville moi j'ai
pris connaissance de vos travaux
lorsque j'ai fait un reportage qui
portait sur les dangers d'une
surexposition des aînés à la télévision
au fait d'être devant un écran où il n'y
a rien qui se produit où on ne bouge pas
et il y avait le contre exemple qui
étaient donnés c'était votre auditoire
votre recherche
est ce que vous êtes intéressé par
hasard et allemands aux effet plus
négatif du nom interactions visuel du
fait de recevoir l'information sans
réagir
oui la plupart des études ils regardent
des territoires de la stimulation
cognitive mon en génération les styles
définitivement ça favorise de déclin
comme ça limite le déclin cognitif avec
l'âge mais elle le fait d'être quelqu'un
qui écoute passivement la télévision
trop long du mât mais surtout des halles
en jeu par la démission qui sont
stimulantes collectivement parce que
c'est autre chose si on écoute une
émission comme la vôtre
on n'a pas de nouvelles de choses mais
c'est sûr que quelqu'un qui est qu'ils
écoutent la télévision de façon passive
il est précis
les sédentaires puis il est passif donc
effectivement c'est probablement faux
idéale devant longue exposition
télévisuelle bascule chez une personne
aînée or donc vous vive la web télé mais
tout à fait ça
une dernière question suivante honda
table pendant qu'on on complète de notre
entretien avec le docteur belleville
mais bon est-ce que vous avez rencontré
des années aînés qui avaient déjà joué à
mario 64
au moment où marine 104 articles parce
qu'un gars qui s'attaque en même temps
que ses sorties moi je me souviens
d'avoir joué dans le 64 quand ils cagnes
est sorti alors est ce qu'il ya un
examen oui j'ai déjà joué à ça ou d'un
côté je pense que jagger et ouest qui
était celui qui est et benson leur qui
sont les deux les deux personnes qui
testait effectivement les années
pourrait lui répondre que moi mais ce
que je peux vous dire c'est qu'hier
fallu limiter notre recrutement des gens
qui à défaut de jouer avec le système
fils joe des joueurs en pleine forme
allemand évalue les faits parce que les
bisons l'art déjà chacun perroquet mon
petit fils mais on a beau jeu dans la
chercher des gens qui n'étaient pas des
joueurs de jeux vidéo donc avait pas
nécessairement une grande première
accusation avec avec mario ou tout autre
du new wave tout à fait bon et dans la
galerie où il ya les u 15 u mais parce
que les différents les faits du jeu sur
le cerveau versus l'effet du cerveau qui
est logique je vous explique t on fait
une corrélation si on dit par exemple
savez tous les jeunes qui jouent à des
jeux vidéo ils ont uni portant une
petite qu'on ne sait pourquoi
c est ce que c'est parce qu'ils ont une
hippocampe plus petits qui notamment
attirer vers des jeux de stupéfiants où
est ce que c'est le jeu vidéo bien un
effet sur leur profond pour vraiment
répondent bien cette question il faut
avoir un design comme le nôtre
expérimentale où on randomisés m'est
alloué au hasard les gens aiment
jeux vidéo ou par exemple apprendre la
musique où aucune intervention il l'on
regarde les faits avant et après
l'exposition jeux vidéo c'est comme ça
qu'on peut montrer que le jeu vidéo
aviez eu un effet j'ai rien à voir avec
le fait qu on a une propension à l'île
verte elle ce type de jeu quand on a
déjà un cerveau de s'occuper belles
nuances dans le réseau national et pose
une dernière question celle de savoir
que les aînés et attendait que les aînés
ne sont pas très habitués nous jouons
ensemble d'habitude les parterres à ces
technologies là est ce qu'avant de
commencer l'étude vous êtes passé par
une phase de préformation de ces années
là où les habitués aux manettes et aux
jeux wii un oui bien sûr évidemment on
lisait avec la manière et on avait aussi
ont répondu à leurs questions
numéro téléphone quand il avait des
problèmes ce qui arrivait dans des bus
est donc oui on avait bien sûr ce type
de ce type de service on people préférés
à risation écouter d'achat rebadgée ce
fut un plaisir de vous parler mais je
suis sûr qu'on va renouveler un jour
l'expérience va trouver un prétexte
tu peux très bien jouer avec vous une
nouvelle fois se peut par exemple pour
le du train ou heures pour les voiliers
alors merci beaucoup d'acteurs bulle
sealed iberville professeur titulaire au
département de psychologie
universellement rires je disais qu'elle
avait deux titres avant nos internautes
l'ont vu l'affiché le deuxième site je
le répète je vais le dire que la
première fois ben oui banzaï radio infos
répéter les choses en vérité
scientifique au centre de recherche de
l'institut universitaire de gériatrie de
montréal c'est pas n'importe qui quand
obama
alors écoutez là je vous ramener des
souvenirs on parlait de vous
vos jeunes années machaie rennais
l'admettre vous savez tous on commence à
basculer dans la catégorie des 55
alors on utilisait beaucoup droite les
papilles elle le prend avec bonne humeur
on regarde la vidéo numéro numéro 4
ça va vous rappeler des souvenirs à
certains d'entre vous et à d'autres pans
de l'histoire alors à ben oui ça c'est
le premier mario bah ouais ok appartenu
ça dans les ventes de garage à musique
de notre chance on va mettre son
véhicule ou switch spécialistes et à des
prix en pensant au travail de tous les
obstacles et les 9 x notre chemin
évidemment il ya des preuves et amassé
et le but je bats cette tranche au
travail des vêtements dans chaque monde
il ya quatre tableaux et plus avoir la
plus les mensonges
pour eux le nintendo n'a rien de bien
mystérieux ce n'est que le jeu le plus
intéressant sur le marché c'était ma
maladie apprend mois a joué un peu je
peux pas y montrer c'est quoi les
bouquins jce connaît par coeur mais
qu'en est il de leurs parents mais même
temps mais ils jouent des fouaces au fil
du temps nerveux ce pied en jus
tropicana empêche de faire d'autres
choses aller jouer dehors
belle matin et on veut pas aller déjà
mis juste pour ça toute cette folie du
nintendo n'est pas sans causer certains
problèmes et ils sont en classe puis ils
deviennent est surexcité contre
lorsqu'on porte et on s'est mis la
concentration peut-être lors de l'us
estimé la concentration mais pas
c'était en 1988 il ya trente et un
reportage du magazine actuel sa présence
à dio canada ça vienne notre boîte j'ai
trouvé ça sur nos archives
on parlait des mets frits bien fait sur
le développement des enfants permet pas
encore de développement d'hippocampes à
l'époque qu'on était pas encore rendus
là c'est dérobés ordi rendu là on est
rendu au deuxième tour des grosses
boules à trans bull à terme il y avait
20 boules à perdre un peu plus tôt donc
vous marie chloé avait perdu 20 boules
sur champ moi aussi j'ai aussi et lui
sait pour le moment notre champion avec
les esprits en women mal alors on
affiche à l'écran la deuxième le propos
qui veut lire l'été dernier qu'elle mise
en garde - minces at elle le fait à
l'égard des deux vidéos des jeux vidéo
des jeux vidéo de fera début des jeux
vidéo ils causent une épidémie mondiale
des tendinites
ils causent des problèmes de myopie de
plus en plus précoces ils causent une
augmentation des maladies mentales
vous avez de la difficulté à lire non ce
n'est pas un des ses crises ses écrits à
l'égard des deux vidéos des jeux il
avait l'effectif
et jeu vidéo c'est ça alors quelle est
la première qu'est ce que disait le ms
cet été parce que c à b ou c moi j'irai
à l'excès il cause d'une augmentation
des maladies mentales
oui je dis quand il faut continuer gu
ouais sa phobie plus précoce des
problèmes de quoi moi je dirais belle
cause des problèmes de millas néophytes
les meilleurs people b d'accord ben j'ai
les yeux la même chose mais où diable a
dépensé tendinite étoiles lapan de dire
c'est pas la bonne mais trois si elles
veulent c'est bien d'être applaudi solar
et gilles parent est l'étoile chapelaine
étoiles dans la régie alors écoutez et
attention c'est de cette étude de l'ol
metz et je parlais mais oui c'est pour
ça je suis à 3/10
c'est une comme d'habitude alors qu'ils
avaient la même lancée sous les symboles
il reste plus que 50 vous il en reste
quand même 70 et la reine pour certains
ces moyens c'est moins douloureux
cambodge
alors on pour ce qui de je vais vous
parler des jeux qui joue compulsivement
qu'infliger quelques quelqu'un vous
présentez un spécial sur cette question
c'est donc une maladie mentale quand on
arrête on peut pas arrêter de jouer
parce que bon il faut retourner au jeu
parce que s'installe en descendant c'est
ça alors et ça s'applique à toute forme
de jeu ou si c'est ça c'est ça oui je
peux le risque par exemple la le tri le
véritable ça c'est pas des tiers non non
l'épargné des les devils avant même sa
non moins non mais à quelle personne
vous êtes dit si vous retournez dans des
moments historiques vous dit le d étain
et la paix la tablette elle-même c'est
un jeu
primordial qu'on retrouvait dans à peu
près toutes les tavernes aubergiste
suite oui oh oui merci professeur
d'histoire c'est toute une bibliothèque
oui mais alors écoutez reçu jean
françois biron chercheur à la direction
régionale de la santé de montréal et
réagit aux propos de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé en disant que c'est
un problème ça de santé mentale qui nous
annonce et c'est donc en juin dernier
on les écoute entrevue numéro 28
si la première organisation importante
de santé qui reconnaît le trouble de
jeux vidéo comme un problème de santé
mentale
mais ceci dit cette problématique là et
déjà exploré ce côté aussi de
l'association psychiatrique américaine
née il ya déjà des travaux qui sont là
dessus sans que c'est pas une surprise
pour nous est ce que pour vous qui êtes
un acteur sur le terrain ce que ça
change quelque chose
en fait pour nous ça ne change pas grand
chose actuellement là au niveau de nos
actions dans la lignée de là parce que
c'est sur notre radar depuis déjà
plusieurs années les troupes de jeux
vidéo et dessous problème si vous voulez
de ce que moi j'appelle l'hyper
connectivité qu'ils nuisent larmes des
problèmes lacs sont générés par
l'utilisation des écrans dans la
population
donc il ya des jolies choses qui étaient
en train de se développer et il ya déjà
beaucoup depuis plusieurs années de
préoccupations au niveau de cette
problème c'est que dans les milieux
scolaires ou dans les familles
donc ça ça nous arrive de partout fait
depuis déjà plusieurs années
8 de 10 minutes réalisé par didier notre
collègue et on vous retrouver ça sur la
page web de tam-tam cette semaine cinq
reportages un d'entre eux est celui là
ça s'appelle le trouble du jeu vidéo
déclaré ma maladie mentale par l'om
est ce aux frais d'études qui disent
déjà faire des affaires des choses bien
différentes l'une de l'autre en amenant
une autre et sans qu'ils aient que cet
effet en australie ont près de 2000
jeunes et ses tubes on est ce que si
nous avions peu de ça et on dit est ce
que c'est bon city c'est parfait c'est
la belle ce serait quoi c'est bon pour
nous chaque mot n'a de sens qu'en
contexte au dimanche 5 octobre en fils
ou non alors les jeunes obtiennent ce
qu'ils jouent en tout cas mon jeu vidéo
d'un des meilleurs résultats au niveau
d'un pointage 15 points de plus par
moyen de mathématiques 17 points de plus
que la moyenne en sciences ont donc ça
c'est parce que ça des effets sur
l'hippocampe peut dire de réduction qui
pas quand mais ça doit augmenter autre
chose c'est des choses à vérifier bien
sûr on est prêts pour notre troisième et
dernier jeu à des missions alors on va
vous rappeler qu' il ya 50 boules à
perdre mais c'est le règlement palma on
est négatif elle n'aime pas qu'on parle
de boue elle parle de coups de poing où
elle pointe rebond alors des points ce
fric alors voici notre on affiche à
l'écran
et puis chantal vous disiez 36 millions
de canadiens combien des millions se
considère comme étant des joints de jeux
vidéo 31 millions 20,3 millions 17,1
millions aucune de ces réponses
c'est un sujet important pour nous à
l'émission de parler des jeux vidéo
parce que beaucoup de canadiens qui
jouent à ces jeux peut-être plus que
dans d'autres nations et je vous pose la
question est ce que on connaît le nombre
de canadiens 66 millions qui joue qui se
considère comme étant des joueurs de
jeux vidéo parce que je joue
suffisamment moi je dirais d aucune de
ces réponses d aucune de ces réponses y
ont pâti d' astérix n'ont donc eu donc
vous vous laisser guider par le hasard
très bien c'est compliqué on et 36
millions c'est sûr qu'on n'est pas 31
millions à jouer si on est 30 6 millions
on ne serait pas 31 millions à jouer
j'irai avec le juste milieu 10,9
millions 10,9 millions le numéro c'est
alors on l'attraper moi aussi j'en avais
19 lycées modernes
matt est alors plus réaliste récemment
vous posez la question qui avait pondu
la petite astérix que voilà 23 mai alors
on a que des perdants
la reine pour le rang avec 30 points
seulement cette semaine un coin de poser
ma personne à zéro c'est quelque chose
quand même 3 midi en suisse a dit
l'agent notre homme signera joie que je
les croyais moi je joue mais j'ai pas le
temps je travaille tout le temps et qui
sont cette année plus qu'on dénomme
est-ce que c'est des jeunes est-ce que
c'est davantage 3 millions d'habitants
tourner le dos à ces jeux qui joue
occasionnellement ce que jamais l'avouer
je viens déjà qu'ils jouent pas du tout
y'en a quand même beaucoup de com - lyon
comme moi ne faut pas une fable acide de
la minorité 13 millions d'accord on a
quelque chose de nouveau pour l'image la
semaine le savez à chaque fin d'émission
je vous demande deviner quelle est
l'image la semaine
il n'y a rien qui change au niveau du
début du départ je réponds seulement pas
ou par non à vos questions vous devez
identifier quelle est cette image la
semaine mais je n'ai pas pour vous je
n'ai pas fait le travail est d'aller
chercher cette image pour vous je me
suis remis dans les mains de notre régie
technique je leur lance ce que j'appelle
le défi technique de la régie ils
devront dans les secondes on va calculer
combien de secondes ça prend à voir
obtenir pour vous et l'affiché à la
télévision web de radio-canada
international cette image la semaine
d'accord ok ils ont appris il ya deux
jours
je n'avais pas le choix d'accepter le
défi
non ils n'ont pas trouvé encore non ils
savent pas de quoi vivent plus en plus
ils vont avec des niveaux long de la
semaine
alors c'est vous qui allez les aider de
quoi on a parlé cette semaine les
inondations du ramage
j'ai pensé aux inondations c'est bien
mais c'est ça non non non c'est plus
international que 5 à l'international
internationale ah oui est-ce que c'est
européen oui est-ce que c'est dans un
pays européen dans la baie où monsieur
est à 10 en grande bretagne qu'en
bretagne grande bretagne pourquoi grande
beauté s'appelle archi archi china russe
c'est archi facile à trouver sur le
voici donc l'image de la scène dès que
la région aura un beau petit bébé lebouc
ya plusieurs images mais franchement là
c'est surtout le prince harry quand il
parlait de sa situation
s'ils y trouvent mignon oui tous les
deux tous les trois oui c'est vrai que
c'est très bon vraiment magnifique
c'est ça donc ça c'est une photo sur
plusieurs félicitations à la régie ok
d'accord pour lundi matin
ok ce nouvel a enfin trouvé la russie il
est des états dans l'ordre d'accès aux
ben écoute et moi je suis content il
fait m si on est 17e à peu près de très
bien très bien mais ça tient
moi je dirais très verrouillé se
tiennent les enseignants
je sais qu'on va arrêter l'émission dès
qu'on peut écouter mais les jours du jeu
merci à tout le monde d'avoir participé
aujourd'hui ça m'a fait plaisir de vous
revoir parce que c'est vendredi
[Rires]
[Musique]